good morning Matthew how are you I'm
doing good how you guys doing doing
great how much college football do you
watch um a little bit um you know we're
usually traveling on Saturdays when we
play on Sunday so don't get to see too
much of it but I I try to pay attention
it's not Georgia who would you watch um
I really just like to watch the teams
that are playing well like Alabama's
playing really well Michigan Ohio State
was obviously a good one
Clemson just those teams that are there
playing well at the top did you hate
Alabama when you were playing them oh
yeah SEC I mean I hated everybody we
played but Alabama had I think I was one
on one career but they blew us out at
our place my last year there so uh got a
got a tough spot for them in the heart
oh you go to Georgia but what were the
other two or three teams that you were
narrowing it down to were you recruited
by Alabama yeah
that was that was maybe one of them
probably a little further down the list
I mean why would you say um yeah
oh I don't know I just I'm trying to
remember back it's been a long time um
but I but I believe I believe I was but
Texas for sure was was up there Florida
State both my parents went there so big
FSU fan growing up and maybe Southern
Cal I wasn't a huge I wasn't huge into
the recruiting thing I just kind of want
to get it over with pick a school and go
how tough was it to say no to Texas it
was tough I have a bunch of friends back
home we were Texas alum and fans so they
were trying to push me to go there for
sure but I don't know I just always grew
up watching like Florida State
you know teams down there in the
southeast so I kind of gravitated
towards that how do you explain this
season with what you guys have
accomplished so far and it feels like
every games a close game um yeah every
game has been you know it's been within
seven points really you know it's been a
little wild one we've done a really nice
job of finding ways to win games because
we haven't played you know a 60 game
60-minute game yet on all three phases
and really you know played extremely
well but for for periods of time here
and there we're play
timely football and guys are making
place what are you thinking when you see
craters kick go through the uprights to
beat the Vikings um man I was just I
knew every time he trots out there in
the fourth quarter really any time
snapping the hold is good I know he kind
of he's gonna bang it right through he's
he's been unbelievable
I'm super clutch and and really with you
know some really lengthy field goes I
mean that one to send it in overtime in
Minnesota 58 yards was good from 65 I
mean he was he was incredible he's
Matthew Stafford of my lines joining a
stamp Patrick show how do you loosen
guys up in oh you're finding a few other
people on the bandwagon now right yeah
it's nice it's nice to have them I guess
well uh we'll take a look and get how do
you loosen up guys
inattentional or do you try to loosen
them up in the huddle um you know I just
I'm always just trying to be myself and
in those situations I I love it I love
getting in the huddle with her backing
up to well last week we had to go you
know hit the ball in or to own two yard
line with a way to go down and get a
field goal to uh you know to give us a
chance to tie it and we were able to do
it I'm just I think guys you know feel
comfortable when they see me acting
normal and so that's that's what I go in
and do obviously it's a big moment in
the game I'm trying to push our guys to
be as good as we can possibly be but at
the same time we just got to go out
there and do our jobs nothing
extraordinary would you rather be down
with the ball or up and you're on the
sidelines down with the ball hundred
times out of 100 I just I don't like not
having control of it I'm probably a
little bit of a control freak it's five
I play quarterback but uh you know I'd
like having the ball in my hands with
the chance to win it not that I don't
trust our defense because I've made some
major plays in major games just the
competitor in me wants the ball who's
the quarterback you probably watched
more of and learned or maybe taken some
of their facets of their game and
incorporated in yours um you know
growing up I really watch the you know
being a Dallas kid watch a bunch of Troy
Aikman and then probably second on that
list was Brett Favre you know loved the
way he played how much fun he had out
there and
and how he threw it around and then kind
of you know once I got in the NFL I
think Peyton I'm painting together that
I paid attention to the most and just
watch you know how he operated the line
of scrimmage and you know how he played
was pretty incredible what could you do
what Peyton would you had the freedom to
be able to go to line of scrimmage and
do everything that Peyton does uh yeah
we're running a very similar system to
what he was running his last couple of
years in Denver before Kubiak got there
so you know it's it's a it's a similar
system to that you know we've had some
injuries and some tough spots this year
that have kind of slowed our pace down a
little bit but you know as far as being
able to get to pretty much anything at
the line of scrimmage we have that
ability for sure but you have a fun
audible I mean he had Omaha we use that
map Council is everybody using Omaha
can't we come up with something else
it's just a good you know it just rolls
off the tongue I don't know kind of give
the guys a little half second to know
here we go and then you know we go or if
some teams I've heard are using hurry
hurry
yeah that's just that works as well I
don't know just you gotta have you know
short words with a couple syllables that
work how about a hardball uh yeah that
could work that could work land a
Michigan man I'm just you know I can get
it in there for you
when are the one of the girls gonna be
born um you know they're twins so
they're kind of iffy on the date but uh
it's gonna be probably between you know
late I'd say mid-april probably be our
our go-to time mid April to early April
I'm thinking here are the names for the
girls you ready yep Athens let me get a
pen I'm writing okay writing okay hold
on what happens and in Georgia okay
identical eight how would that go with
your wife oh I don't know
George you have a couple of George's
only uh but I'll tell her since it was
you know live on the radio and all that
you just had to play along that's very
nice of you and by the way you're uh
I think a career high in rushing yards
with five games to go I mean you're in a
shot
your own record yeah I mean 28 to the
new 21 I guess I don't know I'm just
running around having fun no it's it's
been good I've been just trying to help
us win and you know our guys on the
outside are doing such a good job of
getting open that you know teams are
playing a bunch of to man coverage and
man coverage with their backs turned to
me so I'm uh you know getting out there
and having a chance to run a little bit
now you're an athlete you're averaging 6
yards per carry I mean that's we'll take
it yeah I mean you're sort of an Ezekiel
Elliott yeah I mean that's the poor
man's good luck in New Orleans
I'm gonna guess you're gonna have to
score a few points against that old man
Brees you know yeah I saw that game on
Sunday no question well uh whatever
we're cut out for us a good team I
appreciate the look thanks art Lyons
he's Matthew Stafford thank you Matt the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]